what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to
are women okay with sharing high value
men
i was on this
show with donovan it's gonna be every
sunday at around like six i think
eastern time
and it was interesting so before i start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
ring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos my dog is joining me for this one
i just feel like i could use her opinion
okay
are women okay with sharing high-value
men i mean when you say to share i'm not
trying i always put [ __ ] on 2x when i'm
listening by myself
the ignorant are you saying if perhaps
he is just having some casual encounter
and then you're is that what you're
thinking or what were you meaning when
you said that
um
yeah like honestly yeah i wonder i do
wonder you know i just don't
i don't want to know if i'm sharing i
hope i'm not i really hope i'm not um
but you know i mean obviously you know
if he was having some relationship with
someone else i would leave you know
there's
but you and no agree on that and that's
why i want to bring it up is like if it
was a like if it was like a share and it
was like you didn't know about and it
was like a one-time thing
that's something but if it was an
emotional connection and a relationship
and that's a hell no and i'm gone i see
the whole thing
i
would not be okay with sharing
i i didn't really talk too much about
this on the panel but that is just not
my thing i understand why girls would
want to share but i'll take a less
high value guy i guess
or a less alpha guy and just not have to
do that
i think it's really selfish to cheat
even if it's a casual thing i think it's
selfish you could still transmit
hpv you're still lying to the person you
love that is not my thing but i totally
understand like why girls would rather
do it
so
yeah okay like the whole thing like and
i really appreciate you guys bringing it
up and you know chatting to me about it
but it is really anxiety provoking right
this keeps me on my toes because i don't
want to be in that position or even know
if i am showing i don't think i am um
but you know it it's
the risk is there
the risk is that if i like start
dropping my game and what have you it is
there and not everyone's going to agree
with me so many people are going to be
watching
thank you
why are you with why are you with him
why are you with him but actually you
know i've i i would rather be with this
man than a man that has no direction in
life and isn't attractive to me
that's right
and tallulah very very open and honest
they're saying look
i don't want to have to share this guy
um my response to that is listen
when when if and we say this all the
time and women are not going to like to
hear this but
a lot of people say if he loves you he
won't cheat on you no no no if he loves
you he will not let you find out that
you are sharing him with other women
that's very dishonest i disagree with
that i mean look
i think people can love someone and
still do bad things
right
i think that's a given like i don't
think it's as one-dimensional as oh if
he cheats on you he doesn't love you
you're telling me this man
takes care of you does all these nice
things for you
and one lapse in judgment
means he doesn't love you no people can
do bad things and still love you
but where i disagree is i just think
it's very selfish and it's a lapse in
character if you cheat on someone
just like i think it's a lapsing
character like the equivalent of a guy
having sex with another girl
for girls is i think it's a lapsing
character
to accept like attention from other men
so like posting like bikini pictures on
instagram
or like flirting with other guys i think
that's a lapse in character
but
i don't know i understand their point of
view to be honest what are some things
that what are some things that you do to
increase the odds of not having to
share him sexually with another woman
honestly i don't even think i don't
think most men cheat or she's so pretty
i have a girl crush on her
i i'm just gonna put that out there
unless they're
super high value there's reasons why men
cheat it's always he's a dirty he's a
dog but then you hear the other side of
the story if you were to talk to him one
on one in private he was like look my
wife wasn't sleeping with me for a year
or my way yes that's a thing
i think that cheating
just to cheat and cheating because your
wife won't put out is it completely
different
like a guy that's just been sexually
frustrated for so long hasn't had sex in
years he's having sex with someone
now the right thing to do is obviously
i met a guy once that told me he told
his partner because she hadn't had sex
with him in so long that he was going to
start having sex with other people
but you know
i wonder
but there's a double there's the other
side of that argument where it's
i don't want to know i don't want to
find out
and i guess that's a conversation you
have to have pretty early on in the
relationship how do you feel about
cheating
i don't know let me know in the comments
because
that's that's a tough subject i do think
cheating is different for men and women
i do
i think it's worse if a girl does it
because if a girl cheats on you she
wants to leave
if a guy cheats on you
he he was just horny for a hot minute
but
it's still wrong regardless i wouldn't
want to be with the cheater wife put on
150 pounds right so there's you're
saying
that's the other thing gaining weight
i think a lot of men don't communicate
this to their wife um and they just tell
them it's fine even though it's not fine
and they know it's not fine or maybe
they've put on weight themselves
but
yeah that's that's my that's how i feel
about it i i think it's disrespectful to
be with the person you're with and gain
a ton of weight there's levels right i
mean if you popped out six kids your
body
obviously isn't gonna look the same as
it did when
you first started dating clearly but
if you're just existing and you've
gained 50 60 pounds my dude
right
well it's true so you have your standard
womanizer but then there's the guy who's
not getting any or his wife didn't care
to stay attractive to him and that
honestly breaks a guy's heart they're
yeah they're a little bit disney-ish
they know we're going to get older they
know we're going to get wrinkles but
when you show up with an additional
human and weight that's when they're
like yo
oh wow
yeah yeah no i 100 agree with this i 100
if
it's disrespectful to the guy you're
with
and if you don't communicate that
to your partner i don't know i i just i
don't like that he doesn't care that i
even want to sleep with her and then
that's also kind of um
the way that society
sort of puts male sexuality in a bad
light because let's let's do the inverse
right let's say a guy ate 150 pounds and
his wife didn't want to sleep with him
okay right right and like that would be
okay but then when it's the other when
it's male sexuality focused and healthy
male sexual it's not okay either way
it's not
especially as a guy if you don't have
kids
but i do think that like that generally
both people do gain a little bit of
weight when they have kids they don't
have the time they used to but
i don't
know i understand that i do actuality is
like necessary right um and you you can
maintain it at 50 for those of you who
are wondering um
very very fast those are those are my
thoughts on men who stray i just i stay
intimately connected with my man i try
not to be a headache and keep it at that
okay very good excellent uh pearl you
had something to uh to say about the
sharing thing what are your thoughts
there
yeah um i will say that when you date
like my ex-boyfriend was very like
famous um on tick tock i don't
it's not you know but um and famous fame
dude i don't like it people always argue
with me
sorry people are arguing with me when i
say that so they'll be like oh good talk
yeah that's the thing people would
always i'd be my boyfriend's famous when
i was dating him and the first response
is well it's tick-tock it's not real
fame okay i don't
i don't know
people would ask him for autographs when
we went out i don't know what should i
call it
okay so anyways that was the only reason
i said i didn't mean to discount his
accomplishments the man is so talented
he did a lot
yeah i just wanted to to put that in
there so you know i wasn't putting him
down at all um but
um
and when people don't real what people
don't realize is that like oh my gosh
it's not fun to have like girls in your
guys dms all the times and i don't think
a lot of times like girls want these
high value guys and they want these guys
that like are famous or whatever but i'm
telling you now that i've like
like had like you know been with a guy
that's like at that level of fame i
don't know if i would pick it again to
be honest wow because it's
yeah it's not fun janelle i heard you i
heard you huffing and puffing um what
what's going on with you guys
it's not even like and i've been in that
position where you um
were where pearly's been when i was her
age but i'm talking about you know he's
not even famous my my guy's not even
famous you don't even have to be famous
you just have to be like that
do you have rihanna in your man's dms
rihanna messaged my ex-boyfriend
how the f am i supposed to compete
with rihanna
sorry
sorry i mean look it look it she's right
though she's absolutely right that
attractive successful men can get
i don't want
they can hook up with girls basically
wherever she's absolutely right
but let me tell you it's just a
different level when they're famous it
just is i don't care what anyone says
because
it the the
messenger thing like the dm requests
just go on and on and on it's an endless
supply of beautiful women
you know insecure that makes you and i
wasn't trying to complain or you know
i chose that that's what i chose but
you don't realize what you're signing up
for oh my gosh
you really don't you really don't value
guys
basketball player
has you know makes a decent living
there's girl i know there's girls always
a museum and what was annoying is when i
would always look it up he'd be like why
do you even talk about it like he's like
you know of course that's happening but
i don't give a time a day you know so
it's like you know what's happening it's
kind of like
a second note you said basketball player
does he have a friend
sorry i'm kidding i'm kidding oh the
elephant in the room you know it's their
vote
just leave it leave it there because the
more you stir it up the more of an issue
it's really going to be and um but it's
not fun
you're right it's not fun to be strong
enough woman to hang out like that's
that's um like my point is really just
like i don't think a lot of people know
what comes with it
because
like like i don't think a lot like
people think you can have everything and
you you can't you can't and that's what
i was talking about i don't know i think
she took that
as if i was say i was complaining about
or just like saying it to complain
or i was festering it with it i don't
even i'm not even with the guy anymore
my point was girls think they can have
everything and you can't have everything
everything comes at a cost
anyways i'm gonna continue i have like a
guy that's at a certain level and a
certain value and not know that there's
going to be options
i think options listen man um and this
is what i tell men on my side
is you cannot be if if you're a man with
options it's it's going to be obvious
because of the way you are the way
people
uh the way both men and women i was so
tired when i did this video i'm not even
gonna lie to you i just
i slept like
four hours the night before because
a lack of discipline and self-control
really i just was getting some [ __ ] done
and then i wake up in the morning and i
go to this volleyball game and then i'm
out at the game all day we had to travel
to get there and then i come back i
barely make this live stream and i was
so tired i was not on my game at all i
was so tired women react when they are
around you this is just how it is a man
should never say you know i could be
with a younger hotter
no that's i mean listen whether that's
true or not that just comes up and
listen i've done that before i'm not
going to sit here and say that i'm mr
captain [ __ ] red pill alpha male 100
at the time straight don't expect there
it is in the words yeah that is a great
oh my gosh that is a great
advice because
i dated a guy once that would always
tell me about all these girls that
wanted him
and it was such a turn off i'm like dude
i don't care
i don't care i do oh my gosh
do you want me to talk about my exes all
the time i might right now
i'm emotionally damaged at the moment at
the moment but give me a couple months
of therapy i'll be okay i'll be okay
later mossy demonstrate don't explicate
if if you have options trust me your
woman will know that you have options um
let's go back around this panel let's
start with janelle can i answer that one
oh i'm sorry i forgot about that because
i thought it would be obvious so how do
you kevin is so sweet she is so sweet i
love devin
devin is
devin i love love devin how do you feel
um about the whole about this whole
sharing thing what are your thoughts
because your boy your boy here uh i
don't know that you know this but your
boy here is uh i'm high value um i'm an
out dude i'm an alpha i'm an alpha male
i've got a 15 inch i've got a 15 inch
[ __ ] the [ __ ] want your boy uh [ __ ]
out there want to be with you no i'm
just kidding but go ahead go ahead what
are your thoughts
i love devastation well
coming from the point of view of a post
wall four um oh here we go yeah she's
not a four i think that
i feel like devin is one of those people
that would look better in person because
i don't think this lighting
does her any favors just just being
honest
on white people
that type of lighting it's really good
on black people but on white people like
pale
because i kind of have a similar
um i think she's as pale as me i don't
know i'm pretty which is good for aging
i don't care what anyone says i will
never get on the tanning fit craze
because i will age better than all you
girls that tan i'm sorry i'm going to
unless you eat better than me then maybe
not um you know i think
the jealousy thing and the is really
never going to go away you want to see
me get a little bristly have donovan
tell me he's going to miami without me
you know like all of a sudden i'm like
it is what it is um you know i mean but
but
i don't know i think that with age and
also the time that you spend together
uh you learn to just kind of figure out
that those feelings aren't really that
important uh why why not because i can
either be a jealous crazy person or i
can just trust that you're going to do
the right thing for our relationship now
if if you're gonna cheat on me that's
gonna that's
i hopefully i'll never know that's what
i'm hoping you care enough about me that
i never find out
um
you know
yeah because no woman wants that rubbed
in their face and then they're forced
between a hot rock and a hard place oh
jay simpson
yeah uh but you know i as you get older
too you tend to become like a little bit
less insecure and less like oh i caring
about what other people think
yeah
i'm i'm not great with this this is
definitely a flaw of mine i
am jealous i don't that's why i say i
would take a guy that's less
high value
and just not not cheat on me i don't
want to be cheated on that's and i think
it's selfish i stand by that i think
it's selfish because you're literally
only thinking of you when you do it
like i would i would put out as much as
you need me to
but please don't cheat on me that would
break my heart
so
yeah that's that's my view on it and
more about just saying okay i'm going to
focus on
what i bring to the table as far as like
what what is he getting from me that he
can't get from anybody else
and hopefully that's enough to keep them
around that's true
because
obsessing over it is a waste of your
time it is a waste of your time
so
yeah
i i agree with her it's a character flaw
in mine i wouldn't say i obsessed over
it before but it definitely like
bothered me it was it was hard for me i
again i would not pick that again i mean
you know they're always going to be
younger hotter more beautiful smarter
prettier whatever women out there um but
considering how long we've been together
and all of that we've been through too i
think that says a lot
for
for us so so are you trying to tell me
that you're not worried about i am
extremely worried about it
down to miami but i do have a level of
confidence where you know when like
names pop up you know
whatever like who's this janelle who's
tallulah uh who's you know who are all
these female names that i you know like
who are i have enough confidence in
myself and in you to say okay i'm not
gonna question him it'll come out if it
needs to come out so you know and i
think that it's a combination
it'll come out if it needs to come out
that's a great attitude to have
but all the girls that get cheated on
say that
oh but if a lot of girls have that
mentality though if i don't find out
then i don't care
uh which i guess what you don't know
doesn't hurt you and there's no point in
obsessing over it but
i don't know dishonesty
it has a way of biting you in the ass
sooner or later because okay say you do
choose to cheat right what are the odds
that guy does at one time
and that's the problem if there are no
consequences to actions people
don't always do the right thing look
guys if there were no consequences to
getting drunk
i would drink all the time
i would oh my god i would get hammered
but
there's consequences to it so i don't do
it so thank god there are consequences
in life because if we didn't have
consequences to actions
like the world would not be a good place
would i steal if there was no
consequences i like to think i wouldn't
but can i say a hundred percent if i
really needed the money would i steal
maybe possibly and that that's the thing
about life like they always say
they always give these questions the
manosphere that to me are so silly
would a guy cheat if he knew he wouldn't
get caught
yeah a lot of guys would
but there are consequences in life and a
lot of people don't want to deal
with potential consequences
so
i don't know that's that's my view on it
that being confident um and also but not
being complacent so there are some women
who just get super confident oh my man
would never do this blah blah and then
they can act like they're they're act
like they're whatever they want to
because they get like lackadaisical in
their their relationship whereas you can
be
um you could still be have confidence in
in your man but still also be socially
aware uh of what's going on around and
that it's always going to be a
competitive environment so the day that
you stop competing is a day you're
probably going to lose his attention so
you said you're good with the
names like janelle and ally and pearl
and tallulah popping up what about
caitlyn
[Laughter]
not a fan listen listen uh what dev said
is i agree with her a hundred percent
uh yes she's put in the work to she's
put in the work to secure her slot but
guess what the rent is due every day all
right we're not on it we're not on a
one-year lease let's dev i love you to
death but this ain't no long-term lease
that payment is due every day some days
the payment's gonna come a little bit
late some days the payment listen you're
not gonna be on point all the time every
time
but the fact the the fact is is that you
know that i could you know that i could
replace you just like that if i wanted
to and this is not this is not being
disrespectful this is how it is this
helps her to be to to continue to be
attracted to me and it helps keep her i
think devin could replace him like that
i don't know
i know she's older but
i think she'd actually
i hope she never has to do that they're
a great couple so i don't even know why
i'm talking about this but
i found that high quality people
may not be able to have the same exact
replacement regardless of age but you
don't meet people that work hard and
like
are positive optimistic like a lot of
the traits she has are rare just among
people
so
but probably not just like that like
he's a tough find on her toes that's
that's just how it is buy the same token
i can't just be like that and just be
just just slack off no i got it dude i
gotta take it to the limit every [ __ ]
day i gotta push myself physically
mentally financially and motivate my
motivate myself to keep this value that
i have otherwise dev is gonna start to
get bored and dare i say maybe even
unattracted to me at some point so if
you want options gentlemen you have to
present yourself as a man with options
this means keeping your value high and
there's a reason why they say
relationships are work
it it takes an effort from both parts
you can't take it for granted that
someone's always going to be
uh
what is it
loyal to you
you know maintain fidelity when you're
slacking off and really like acting like
you don't care half the time
yeah
this was a great
this was a great clip i hope do you guys
like having my dog
she doesn't have to be here i just
she's so cute i kind of liked having her
on but let me know in the comments if
you guys
want me to keep her on or if you're like
nah
she's too loud and gross
she's a little gross a little bit a
little bit
anyways don't forget to subscribe to the
channel bring that notification bell and
i will talk to you guys next time